Good morning again, church.
What a blessing it is to gather together every Sunday in
this room together
and to be able to worship the Lord together, to be nurtured
as believers and then challenged
to go live sent it is something we don't take for granted,
shouldn't take for granted.
A couple housekeeping items just
before we get into it too far, members,
you're gonna get an email today about, uh,
our financial ministry plan for the next 12 months.
So make sure you take a look at that lot info there.
There's also paper copies out there if you want that,
that would be better for you either way.
Uh, you've also heard me mention our church
app a lot recently.
Just as a reminder that we have one, if you don't have it
yet, you can actually head to hhbc.com/connect.
There's a link there. You can get it easily that way.
Also, I send out an email every week.
I don't know if you even know that that happens,
but uh, hopefully some deep thoughts maybe in there every
once in a while, but then also some events and updates
and some notices
and what's coming up next Sunday, things like that.
So if you want to get that, go to that link
that's on your notes as well.
You can sign up there now. We're ending soon.
Our sermon series called First Things First.
We've been walking through the last couple months about the
core doctrines of our faith.
What are the things that are the,
the distinctly Christian beliefs that we have,
why we believe them, those kind of things.
Uh, the beliefs that we should put into our theological jar.
First, the big rocks.
First things like God's revelation of himself,
his attributes, the trinity, uh, God,
the son incarnate, taking on flesh.
We looked at humanity and what that means about us.
And then also salvation, how person is saved.
And so what we did last week though,
as we shifted away from the big rocks into
the secondary things of our faith, the interpretations
of things that begin
to separate believers into churches and denominations.
Why do we have multiple churches?
Why are there different denominations?
We looked at those kind of things.
We saw that was the smaller rocks that fit in
around the bigger rocks.
'cause remember, if somebody has the same big rock beliefs,
then they're brothers and sisters in Christ
and we're in this together
and we're gonna be together forever, uh,
with God in eternity.
And so that's where we have to land, that those are brothers
and sisters and we're not against them.
We're on the same team of those
who would believe those things.
Now next week, as you've watched the video now
so many times, you know, something else is coming next week
where we're gonna get into the third level things
that differ among believers,
that we can still be in the same church together
and differ on some of those beliefs.
And so we're gonna get into the sand of our faith,
especially regarding Christian liberty, meaning
what we have the freedom to do
or not do as believers and why.
So we're gonna get into that next week.
Uh, hint hint, that is the final sermon
series of the series.
So just know that's coming.
Before we get to the sand though, today
what I wanna do is articulate one of the distinctives
of our church, one of the theological principles
that we hold as very important here.
So it's kind of a small rock to us, you might say.
It also points to a lot of big rock items.
Yet at the same time, I don't want it to be seen
as something that you have to fully align on in order
to be a part of our church.
We're not giving theological tests
as people walk in the door, right?
So the idea here is yes, it's a small rock, it's a big deal
to us and you'll hear it,
but it's also got qualities of sand that you can differ
and still be here.
So what I'm talking about is commonly known
as reformed Theology.
Theology. And lemme just say upfront, this is hard.
It's hard, especially
because to some of you,
this will be completely new information.
Never even heard anything about this before.
Okay, great, let's talk about it.
But it's also hard because it has some gnarly words in it,
like predestination, an election free will, how
that all works together, how God saves,
what's our part like there, there's all of that
gnarly conversation
that can really trip people up along the way.
And it's been debated for hundreds, if not thousands
of years about these things.
I'm gonna fix it here in 30 minutes, right?
No, it's just part of the, the hard part of this.
That's why my hope is to clear up what we even mean
when we say that a little bit.
And also to clear up some misconceptions, some,
some caricatures.
What caricatures of those things in a lot of the ways
as well, just to clear some things as along, along the way.
But, but also one of the goals is that we, we shouldn't have
to be angry about these things.
We shouldn't be antagonistic about these kinds of things.
And so I hope to show you there a little bit.
So again, lemme just be clear.
If you differ on some of these nuances of these things, then
let me say to you, you're welcome here.
This is something that we want you to know
that even though we're, we don't talk about it a whole lot,
I'm not doing sermon series on this,
I'm just just letting you know that it's gonna be the flavor
that you do kind of catch over time here.
This is, this is where we stand back here, but, but,
but you'll see where the big rock items are and
and that's where we're together on.
So we can walk towards that as you'll see.
But here's the other reality of this.
A couple weeks ago I preached on the last things,
the end times that there's some of that that we won't know
until the end, until it actually happens.
We just won't know, maybe even not know at all.
There's parts of this that will be like that as well.
That there's a mystery in how God does this sometimes.
And theologians have debated
and discussed that throughout the generations there's some
of this that we just won't be able to grasp.
And that's okay because the Lord is the Lord and we're not.
We should seek to understand and try to and we will.
But let's also be gracious with this
as we go forward knowing that there's differences.
But there's also stuff we're just not gonna
grasp as we walk into this.
Now I wrestled of course with how to even present this.
How do I go through this today?
Well, I believe the Lord just said let my word speak. Okay?
So take your copy of God's Word
and turn with me to the book of Ephesians.
Paul's letter to the Ephesian church in the New Testament.
Be in Ephesians chapter one verses three through 14 today.
Really one long sentence in the original language
and we're just gonna see what it teaches us about who God is
and how he works and what he does.
I'm gonna read it all and then we'll pray.
Ephesians one, three through 14,
blessed be the God
and Father of our Lord Jesus Christ,
who has blessed us in Christ
with every spiritual blessing in the heavenly places, even
as he chose us in him
before the foundation of the world, that we should be holy
and blameless before Him in love.
He predestined us for adoption to himself as sons
through Jesus Christ according to the purpose of his will,
to the praise of His glorious grace
with which he's blessed us in the beloved in him,
we have redemption through his blood, the forgiveness
of our trespasses according to the riches of His grace,
which he lavished upon us in all wisdom
and insight making known to us the mystery of his will,
according to his purpose, which he set forth in Christ
as a plan for the fullness of time
to unite all things in him, things in heaven
and things on earth in him,
we've obtained an inheritance having been predestined
according to the purpose of Him
who works all things according to the council of his will.
So that we who were the first to hope in Christ might be
to the praise of His glory in Him.
You also, when you heard the word of truth, the gospel
of your salvation and believed in him were sealed
with the promised Holy Spirit who is the guarantee
of our inheritance until we acquire possession of it
to the praise of His glory.
God, thank you for your word, this beautiful picture
of and reminder of the gospel of our salvation.
God, I pray even as difficult as some
of these things might be, I pray you give us
in our hearts good soil to be receiving the word
and bearing good fruit from the word
I pray you would remove any barriers in our minds,
the clutter of the weak that could easily trip us up today.
I pray you strip that away, that we can just see you
and focus on you today.
And your word protect us from the enemy who wants to
snatch away what you're planting in us.
So God help us, protect us, teach us Holy Spirit.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
Okay, so how could we summarize the entire passage
that I just read with one sentence
and could that sentence be a limited
but helpful summary of reformed theology?
Well, here's an effort.
It's not the only one,
it may not be perfectly right either, but it's an effort.
This is what we're gonna work from today, is
that salvation is God's work alone.
Salvation is God's work alone.
It's all over this passage right now.
The genesis of that phrase is actually from the 15 hundreds
and what we call the Protestant Reformation.
And what had happened at the time is
that the Roman Catholic Church had drifted so much into
salvation by works that there was group of a group of people
who started to read the Bible in their own language
and they started seeing things that that didn't match.
And so they felt a need to reform the church.
And so they began working and teaching and writing and
and opposing in many ways in a helpful way that
that was summarized and their, their beliefs of
how they opposed it was summarized
and what we we know as the five solas.
Now the word sola is a Latin word meaning only or alone.
And so they, they summarized it.
And this is some way we've kind
of systematized it in our day as well.
But let me just read these five to you,
that they summarize their beliefs, scripture alone,
Christ alone, faith alone, grace alone
to the glory of God alone.
If you wanted to have a, just a simple summary,
it doesn't say everything, but it says enough of
what they believed in opposition to
what was happening in the Roman Catholic Church.
And so that means that God's word is the final authority,
not the church, they're reading the Bible.
It's what was driving everything.
And what they saw was that salvation is by grace alone
through faith alone in Christ alone, all
for the glory of God alone.
So that's what they wanted to make sure
that they saw from the Bible,
that they were communicating out against
what they had been hearing.
And again, we saw that here in Ephesians one, right?
We saw God accomplishing salvation.
I'm gonna break this whole passage down into three sections.
The first section is this, that we, we learned here
how God accomplished salvation is the
Father chose his people.
First thing we learned about this, how God did it.
He chose his people.
There's no way around this that in verse four,
God chose those who are now believers.
Verse five, he predestined us,
which basically means he chose the end state ahead of time.
And listen, I say that
and I even as I wrote it down as I say it right now, I too,
I know some of you struggling with that.
I too can struggle with the implications of that.
Like I get it. I, I feel it.
But the truth of the matter is
that there was no other way any
of us would have been saved except for God doing this.
Because the effect of sin is not just that we kind
of miss the mark, the effect of sin is so comprehensive
that none of us could initiate a saving response to God.
It was an unconditional act of grace for him to save anyone.
He didn't have to and none
of us could have made it ourselves.
And yet he did as an act of His grace.
But, but here's one of the misunderstandings of this.
Don't think that God in eternity past just merely looked
ahead and saw who would eventually choose him
so then he would choose them.
No. Because in some way if that's true,
then we're compelling God to choose us
by something we've done.
No, that is not how this works.
God saves merely by his own will,
sovereign will for his own reasons.
And that is what this scripture teaches.
Now, even Calvin himself
kinda wrestled with this a little bit.
This is what he said. Although we cannot conceive either
by argument or reason how God has elected us
before the creation of the world.
We know it by his declaring it to us.
Like we don't know how this works.
I really can't explain it fully, but we know it
because God told us and that's enough.
Now we should seek to understand it and we will.
But that's enough that God chose his people.
But don't get stuck on that too long
because there's reasons why God did this.
We need to see what he cho chose his people for.
And we see it in verse five.
He said it was for adoption to himself as sons of
through Jesus Christ.
So he chose for adoption.
Now why does it not say sons
and daughters like, is salvation only for men?
Is that, is that what he's saying here?
No, he's actually elevating women
because the inheritance idea throughout this passage was
talking about the sons
of the family splitting up all the stuff he's saying.
Now all believers split up God's stuff in a sense.
They receive the inheritance.
So both men
and women who are saved are included in that elevate.
Praise God because that's true.
So the fact that God adopts all of us
as sons is important here.
'cause that means we all get it And don't miss something He,
he said it was done in love, right?
Those couple words right before verse five, he says in love.
So build this image in your head with me for a minute.
Take a take a ride in your brain to somewhere right now
that you, you are an orphan
and you're in the worst orphanage you can ever imagine.
And you're picturing that in your head and
and so you're sitting there and you feel hopeless,
you feel forgotten.
You feel like there's no future. Yet the
wealthiest family in the world walks in the front door,
looks at you and says, I choose you because I love you.
Can can you feel like the joy you would
experience in that moment?
You can't even conceive of everything that involves yet.
But you know, like I'm, I'm, I'm free.
I'm out. I'm a part of a family.
Look at, look at all like you can see the joy
that would come as a result of feeling that that's
what God has done for you.
Believer infinitely more than even
what the wealthiest family on earth can provide
for you infinitely more.
He says, blessed us
with spiritual blessings in the heavenly places in Christ.
That's so much more.
It's what he's done by adopting you into his family.
Not because of your works. Like you can't earn
adoption by works, right?
It's not because of your works. It's because he loves you.
One John three, one, see what kind
of love the father has given to us
that we should be called children of God.
And so we are, this is love.
So he chose for adoption,
but there was a second reason God chose.
We saw, saw the universe. Four.
He says that we should be holy and blameless before him.
He chose his people for holiness as well,
for adoption and for holiness.
Now he's not saying just so we would live holy lives,
he's saying that he would make us where we could stand
before him spiritually blameless.
'cause here's the reality on our own, you
and me, every one of us on our own, we are
absolutely guilty before God.
We are radically corrupted by our sin, unable
to clean ourselves up and left to ourselves.
None of us would choose God.
None of us would move toward God.
Romans three says, none is righteous. No not one.
No one understands. No one seeks for God.
This is the reality of every one of us,
apart from any intervention by God, we're heading
that way, separated forever.
Yet, yet, God reached into our lives
and through Christ's atonement on the cross, he takes us out
of that and sets us apart as righteous spiritually.
That we are now washed, clean.
Like you know the song, sing it with me.
So don't sing by myself. Jesus paid it all.
All to him.
I owe sin had left
a and stain.
He washed it wide as snow.
So I know it's hard at times to understand
how this all works out,
but God choosing his people in the end is
a good thing, right?
For adoption, for holiness to make us right before him.
So that's the first section of this passage.
The Father did something else though here in the second
section that he set forth his son is the way it says it.
He chose his people. He set forth his son.
Look at verse seven. What are the first two words
that we have in English here?
The first two words of verse seven. What does it say in him?
Now there's a lot of the word him throughout this passage.
So the question is, who's who's he talking about?
Which hym is he talking about?
Well, right in verse six, in the beloved who's the beloved?
Well that's, that's the son of God.
The means of God's grace
to us in a way is the Son the beloved in him.
The Father set forth this purpose of redemption.
He he set forth the Son in the flesh for redemption.
We see it here through this God
man's perfect blood.
We get forgiveness. His death gave
us something.
He purposely atoned for the sin of all of those
who verse 12 says, would hope in Christ that faith,
the belief that verse 14 talked about, that we believe
that's how his death counts for ours.
It's not just universally applied
'cause then everybody would be saved.
No, he's saying those who hope in Christ.
And so it's not just about being a good person,
it's not just about being around church all the time.
It's not even that your parents are Christians
and so they bring you to church all the time
and you just kind of assume
by default you're a Christian too.
No, that's not how this thing works.
This word redemption illustrates the idea that you
and I are slaves that need to be bought back.
We need to be redeemed.
And the only sufficient payment
to redeem us was the blood of Christ.
So he set forth his son
for redemption, but that wasn't it.
The Father also set forth his son for restoration.
It says for redemption, but also for restoration.
Verse 10 says,
Christ will unite all things in him heaven and on earth.
That's restoration language.
The fracturing that we experience every day will not
always be the way it is.
All this that's broken and divided
and separated will one day be restored in Jesus,
which in fact is what he's even doing right now.
Why do you think the New Testament letters over
and over again talk about unity?
Because the unity of his people in the church
is an illustration, a foretaste of the glory that's coming,
that this is an example of something that will be fully
and finally done one day in his presence forever.
The future kingdoms breaking in through his people,
restoring us.
There's actually a third reason the father
set forth his son.
It's for possession, so for redemption, for restoration,
and for possession.
Look carefully at verse 11 again.
The way it reads in English is in him we've obtained an
inheritance that seems like at first glance we
receive the inheritance.
Well in verse 14 we do.
But in the original language, this actually talks about
how we are made an inheritance.
In other words, we become the possession of God
through his predestining purpose and will.
It means that we are his both now and forever.
We are made into that.
Now we've come a long way already
and all that's a lot I know,
but we're actually not finished yet.
There's more here. Verses 13
and 14, show us why the Father sent his spirit as well.
So the father chose his people.
The father then set forth his son,
but then he also sent his spirit.
We see it in verses 13 and 14, God accomplishing salvation.
Look at this piece, verse 13 in
him, that's in Christ.
You also, when you heard the word of truth, the gospel,
your salvation believed in him, were sealed
with the promised Holy Spirit who is the guarantee
of our inheritance until we acquire possession of it
to the praise of his glory.
So why'd the Father send his spirit first
to seal the promise that was clear, right?
It's what it said to seal the promise.
Jesus said it. The Old Testament said it.
This is what was coming in salvation.
The Holy Spirit was coming to his people.
What happens when someone trusts in Christ, when they repent
and believe, when they hope in Christ as this scr,
this said, the Lord sends his Holy Spirit into that person
to seal you.
Now that word seal is like when you think
of a brand on a horse, what does that illustrate?
What does the brand mean?
When a horse has a brand, it means ownership, right?
It's who possesses that horse.
The Holy Spirit sealing us, branding us, marking us,
says, God says, you are mine.
We're marked sealed. God says, that's mine. You are mine.
Which is why verse 14 says, the Holy Spirit is sent
to guarantee our eternity, right?
So it seals the promise.
God says, you're mine covenant promise,
but then also it guarantees our eternity
we're already owned.
And if you are his, you're his forever.
The Holy Spirit guarantees he never backs out of
that covenant.
It's the word guarantee here.
The word in the original language is like when you put a
down payment down on a house, right?
You put some money down, a lot of money down
and you say, Hey, I'm promising to pay the rest
of it over time, right?
But don't push that metaphor too far
because here's the reality, you
and I, when we put money down on something
to pay the promise later, we
can back outta that deal, can't we?
But God can't, he never changes.
He's good on his promise. So when he says,
notice when he says the down payment
of your eternity is the Holy Spirit in you,
he's good on paying the rest.
That inheritance is good for us for eternity.
He's promised it, he's guaranteed it
and he's going to give it.
That's why someone who is truly saved will persevere
if the Holy Spirit is in that person
as the guarantee of eternity.
If he truly owns that person, then
that promised future's guarantee.
It might be a meandering road to get there,
but it's guaranteed.
So again, let's go back to the top on this.
As we saw at the beginning
and all throughout Ephesians one,
salvation is God's work alone.
This is what God does. He chose his people.
He set forth the redeemer not just to offer salvation,
but to actually accomplish salvation.
And God sent his spirit to ensure that it is completed.
Now, notice something. Everything I just said
is not something I'm saying just
because it's in some systematic theology textbook or
because we read it in an article online
that somebody came up with.
This is what God's word says. It's right here.
It's direct from it.
Now, I know some of you're thinking
of tensions that that comes up.
You'd think of other scriptures, you're thinking about
what about this, but what about that?
And there are tensions that inevitably arise.
We're gonna try to deal with some
of those on Wednesday night a little bit
in our digging, deeper time.
But here's the point. The point of this
is that we start with God.
What I mean by that is our theological framework has
to start top down like this.
This idea, not, not, don't think convertible, top down,
like driving around on a beautiful day, like top down, up
to down, like top down theology, meaning we start
with God, it's about him.
And then we try to answer the questions that will come from
that rather than starting bottom up, start with us
and then try to answer the questions
that come from there, right?
We have to choose which way we start from.
And so we've chosen to start top down, start with God,
answer the questions in light of that
and wrestle with some of the implications in light of that.
We believe that's the right way
to do theological principles.
Now, everything I've said is absolutely important.
As we've seen in scripture in many ways, I just kind
of skimmed the top of this thing
and maybe created more questions than answered any.
But the next question naturally
follows, okay, that's all great.
We've done all that. What do we even do with all this?
Like how do we respond to that?
Right? Because that's the question.
We can have all these, these
beautiful theological principles.
The questions, what do we do with that? This is hard.
What do we do with it? Well, here's I pick three.
There's probably way more. Here's, here's the first one.
When we honestly look at everything
right here in Ephesians one, the implications, the ideas,
we look at the truth of saving his people.
We look honestly at those things.
It should create humility.
We lay down this text in front of us.
It should create in us a humble heart, right?
I mean, we deserve none of it,
and yet God did it.
There's no way we could earn this.
There's nothing we could do yet God did it.
We should never be arrogant about these truths.
We should never be antagonistic about these truths.
We should never walk around kind of self righteously,
smug about these truths
because the idea of undeserved grace
should drive us to our faces.
Bowing before this great God, never thinking that,
that somehow we're better than anybody else.
The ground is level at the foot of the cross.
And so we come to him there by his grace.
One of the markers of our church should be a true deep
humility where we walk around
almost dumbfounded
that God would even include us in this thing, right?
Like, I deserve hell.
I deserve separation, I deserve wrath.
And yet he chose to save me.
Like, and we're just dumbfounded as we walk around, just
so grateful for what God has done.
It should create humility.
The second is, should cultivate mission,
these truths should cultivate mission.
I know right now some of you're
wondering how that even works.
Like, wait a second, I thought,
I thought these beliefs meant that were not supposed
to be missional, salvation's, all of God.
So what? Why do we even need to do anything?
What salvation is of God?
But the means that he has ordained salvation to come,
the gospel to come is by using people like you
and me to proclaim it to other people, right?
Sandwiched in the middle of Romans nine through 11,
which is like the preeminent election text in the middle
of it, in Romans 10, he says directly,
how can they believe unless they hear?
So the idea for us, we saw even here in Ephesians one,
when you heard the word of truth
and believed in that gospel of your salvation.
So there's a measure of this is how you
and I are, how God gets the gospel to people.
But here's what else it does.
This idea of election, this idea
of God's effective call should also give us a healthy
confidence as we go.
Because what that means is there's no pressure on
me or you anymore.
In the mission of God, it's up to God to save, right?
That takes the pressure off of me, takes the pressure off
of you that all he's calling us to do is scatter the seed.
He's calling us to be these farmers out there tossing seed
everywhere and anywhere.
Now we can get better at doing that, yes.
But our job is to sow the seed of the gospel broadly
and let God do his work.
Yet when we go, when we scatter that gospel to all nations,
we scatter it to all people we meet.
We're not supposed to be discriminate about how we
who we choose to give it to, right?
We're to call all to repent and believe.
When we do that, because of these truths right here,
we can be sure that some will be saved.
And listen, it has nothing to do with
how persuasive I am as I share the gospel.
It has nothing to do with how bold I
am as I share the gospel.
It has nothing to do with us playing five verses of just
as I am to break someone down emotionally
enough that they finally come.
No, salvation is God's work.
So he'll save. We sow the gospel
seed in confidence.
I preach up here every week or every somebody else preaches.
Every week you talk to your neighbor every day,
potentially you pray for your family every moment, right?
You're praying that God would do his work.
And we do that in confidence
because we know God will save some
even from the hardest places.
Remember, revelation five, all nations,
all people groups are represented there.
So when somebody goes at the risk of their life,
they go in confidence knowing
that God's got some in there, somebody is gonna be saved.
And so we go in
confidence as we go on mission.
We should be humble.
Go on mission. But finally, the third one,
these truths should compel praise.
They should compel praise.
As we went through this passage, I didn't tell you
how I broke it up and why, but you saw three sections.
And I want you to see how I got to those three sections.
Look at the, uh, start of verse six, the end of verse 12,
the end of verse 14.
Those are the ends of the section breaks, right?
What does verse six say to the praise of his glorious grace?
Verse 12 ends to the praise of his glory.
Verse 14, the end to the praise of his glory.
Now, when you're reading the Bible
and you see something repeated like that,
that means it's important.
And each section, father, son, spirit, he does end
to the praise of his glory.
So catch what this is telling us.
Now, in all three of these sections, what the Father did
to adopt his people, what he did to set forth his son
to redeem and restore what he did by sending his spirit
to seal and guarantee he did all of that so
that we would praise him even more.
He says, to the praise of his glory, it's
so we would praise.
He's already gracious, he's already glorious.
He's already worthy of praise.
But listen, he receives even more glory
by saving sinners like you and me.
He doesn't have to. And he had
to do everything it took to make it happen.
So he is the one who gets the glory even more through
salvation of sinners.
Like that is glorious, right?
And so let me just talk for a second to, to a few of you
that maybe, maybe right now you're feeling a, a bit
of a stirring in your heart.
That you're, you're realizing that you're a sinner in need
of a savior like this, and you're strangely warming
to these truths.
Maybe it's been a while. Maybe you've been kind of dealing
with this for a couple weeks or months,
and now you're, you're starting to see again and again.
Listen to me, that's not me doing that.
That's not a preacher being persuasive enough
that emotionally you're starting to feel something.
No. That that is the Lord working in you right now.
That's the Lord drawing you to himself right now
because you would not come up with
that on your own in ourselves.
Again, you can't create a desire for God.
And if he's giving you this sense of like, I, I,
I think I want to know more and I wanna know who he is.
That is the Lord at work within you.
It's God's voice that is drawing you to himself.
And so what do you do with that? You respond in hope.
Like Ephesians one said, you believe
the way Jesus said it is you repent
and believe you turn from your sin
and say, okay, that got me in trouble.
That got me condemned forever. Jesus.
I want what you give me. I can't do anything about that.
I need you. And you hope in Christ,
believe the gospel of your salvation
and all of this that he promised he'll give you.
So please, we'd love to talk with you about that afterwards
with somebody you came with.
Talk to them about it. We'd love to hear.
I mean, I talked to somebody
before the first service who told me their story of how
this day they were completely opposed to the gospel.
The very next day they said, no, I love Jesus. I want him.
Where does that come from? Completely opposed.
And he said, the next day I was like, I want
that it's God's work.
It wasn't somebody convincing him,
it wasn't somebody being persuasive enough.
It was God changing his heart.
Powerful. So don't give up praying for somebody, by the way.
But then I also wanna talk to the rest of us,
those who are believers.
Here's what my prayer was all week.
That our hearts by these truths,
that our hearts would be fanned into flame in a new way
by seeing these truths that we may have missed
or may have forgotten, that we would see it.
That, that we would be so stirred in our hearts
that something would trigger to say,
man, God, you're worthy.
And that even just in this room, the roof,
the roof would lift off this place
because we're so passionate about our praise.
But then not only that, we would also walk out of here.
And every day of our lives we would see is
for the praise of His glory.
And we'd live differently for his glory
because of these truths.
'cause this is our God church.
We shouldn't care what other people think about us
as we respond to him
because we're so stunned by the reality that he would choose
to save sinners like us.
That's the point. He's made us different.
Listen, he's holy, he's sovereign.
He doesn't have to save anyone, but he's grace, he's love,
and he's made a way
and blessed us more than we can ever imagine.
That's what compels praise church.
So let's proclaim all that he's done in here,
but out there proclaiming the glory of our savior king.